Okay. Good morning. I think we'll get started so we
can stay on time.
I want to welcome you all to this session, Strengthening
the Oncology Trial Ecosystem through Operational and
Regulatory Innovation. I'm Lola Fashoyin Ajaye.
I'm a medical oncologist. I'm currently a consultant.
I'm a former
regulator at the US FDA, and I'm
happy to have been invited to moderate this session with the
esteemed panel that we have here.
I want to just bring your attention to a
QR code which has gone missing now.
Is it on the next slide?
Okay.
There is a QR code.
Where is the QR code?
Am I not seeing it?
It'll pop up again during the poll.
It'll pop up during the poll?
Yeah.
Okay. All right.
It'll show up at some point.
These are my disclosures.
So I want to provide some context to this session.
There have been shifts in
the historical patterns of drug development that I know we're
all aware of. This session isn't focused on
describing, characterizing what those shifts are.
But I think we are seeing increased
innovation
that is originating in China, as an example.
We're seeing changes in the regulatory environments in
other global regions outside the United States.
And this is leading to a smaller
proportion of enrolled participants in global trials who are
coming from the United States. And so this session is really
an attempt to
delve into some detail on
potential solutions
to addressing what FDA is expecting with
respect to US population
representativeness in global oncology drug development.
And I listed on this slide some
relevant guidances that really describe what those expectations are with
respect to participant demographic representativeness
to ensure that the data that is generated is generalizable to the
US population and its diverse population.
But also a guidance on evidence
generation in global
oncology drug development, which is really an attempt to bridge
the policies around study
representativeness or population representativeness with the fact that
most oncology drug development is global.
And how do you marry these two important and critical
concepts in developing strategies to
improve the quality of the data that is
generated during clinical investigation and clinical research?
And so we also are addressing this
issue because there are real
potential and real
observable impact of the lack of a
US representativeness in these global
trials as they may result in delayed timelines to
completing studies, but also may delay or
preclude approval from the US FDA.
So there have been discussions that were ongoing even before
FDA articulated its expectations in
guidance.
And a lot of this discussion really centers around the
feasibility and the challenges, but also the
opportunities
to find solutions to address a number of issues that are
really impacted by these global drug
development programs, including things like clinical trial design,
how to really accommodate potential
variability in standard of care across the globe, how
you define the study population. A lot of operational
considerations here at the site level,
what are the barriers to activating
trials quickly, issues around contracting which really
delay and have adverse impact on timelines,
as well as trial level issues, which we've been discussing for many
years. Trial initiation, feasibility, patient
engagement,
and clinical trial access. And then sort of
broader medical research system
issues and barriers that really
raise other considerations around clinical trial
availability,
patient access to clinical trials, referral processes, and so forth.
And so we hope to really focus today's
conversation on a few of these issues.
But I want to bring your attention to the fact that AACR
has really been committed to addressing this issue for a
number of years, convening various stakeholders to do so,
and leading to some discussions and major symposia
in previous annual meetings, including one in 2023, where the
discussion centered around how to select sites to
ensure that you are including the US population in
this evidence generation process.
And then last year in discussing FDA's guidance, which I
referencedBefore, and talking about some
practical
barriers and challenges. So for today's discussion,
we're not going to relitigate what all the issues
are. I think many of you in the room know what the issues are.
We're going to touch upon them, but as a basis for the
solutions that the panel will be proposing.
And I hope, and I would like to engage you all in this
conversation,
because in a one and a half hour session,
it is not possible to have all the viewpoints represented on our
panel.
And so the folks whose perspectives are represented here
are in no way at all reflective of whether we think these are more important
perspectives than others. It's just really practical
consideration. So I fully expect that you all will come to the
podium and answer some of the questions that I will be posing to
the panelists to provide your perspectives on the
issues that we'll be discussing. So today we'll focus on
describing very briefly the operational challenges at site
and trial level, and also
importantly focusing on what are operational
regulatory policy solutions to ensure that evidence
generation really addresses patients' needs.
And this conversation will
really focus on the US ecosystem. But again, I
want to make sure that we remember that the context
here is that we have global drug development, but we're focusing on
specific barriers as they relate to the US.
All right. So before we start, I want to introduce our
panelists. I'm going to invite them to introduce themselves.
I want to make a disclaimer here that the views that they will
be providing are their own and do not necessarily reflect the
views of their institution. So we'll start with
Mark, and I'll be referring to them by their first names. I hope that's okay.
Thank you. My name's Mark Stewart.
I'm Vice President of Science Policy at Friends of Cancer Research.
Our organization's really focused on regulatory innovation to speed the
development of new drugs for patients, and this is a topic that we've
been
exploring and thinking about critically, given just the vast
implications, particularly when it comes to the regulatory review and
evidence to support many new drugs that are coming to the
agency.
Hi, everybody. I'm Jay Lebsack. I serve as the Vice President for Clinical Research
Operations at Moffitt Cancer Center in Tampa, Florida.
Hi, I'm Judy Fitzgerald. I'm a 17-year bilateral breast
cancer survivor and patient advocate, and I'm affiliated
with Citrus for Prevention and Advocates for Collaborative
Education.
Okay.
Hi, everyone. I'm Bea Lavery. I'm Vice President of Regulatory Affairs and looking
at the clinical strategy across all of our therapeutic areas in our portfolio.
Hi, I'm Vanna Mek Bernstam. I'm Chair of Investigational Cancer Therapeutics, which
is the Phase one program at MD Anderson, and we talk about trial activation every
day.
Yeah. Thanks so much, Lola, for having me on this panel.
I'm Terryl Baptiste, and I lead Oncology Regulatory Policy and
Intelligence at Gilead. And I think one of the things that really excites me
about this work is our urgent need for speed on this.
Every day that we delay this means that patients
have to wait longer for their treatments.
And I think we're going to have a lot of discussion about
solutions today. But I think,
and Lola does a great job of saying it, but I thought
about it in terms of three Cs. So we have congestion in the system right
now. We have too many vendors, networks, and players, and that congestion
leads to confusion, and that confusion leads to
collision. So we have a lot of
wasted time and damaged relationships from not
working together. And so I think this panel is about really working together and
everyone working together.
All right. Thanks for those introductions.
So I'll invite Mark to come and give your
anchoring presentations. We'll have two presentations, and then we'll delve into
the discussion. Thank you.
All right.
Thank you, ACR, for coordinating on this session and providing
a venue to discuss this topic,
and for bringing together this group of folks.
As Lola noted, there are far-reaching
implications related to this topic.
Most notably, equity and access
challenges,
but also important regulatory implications,
especially as more evidence is being generated through
multi-regional clinical trials,
and the realization that many of these data
sets often have low or no US
representation
in them. And so today I want to walk you through some
data that we've generated through a survey that I
think provides some insights around the operational realities
faced for site activation in the US
in oncology trials, and more importantly, how US compares
globally and where some of the delays might be occurring
in this process.
So I have no disclosuresSo
as noted, I'm going to show you some data today that we collected
through a survey. And the objective was really to benchmark
site activation timelines and identify sources
impacting US oncology trial activation
through a structured survey that we distributed to
major pharmaceutical companies that have oncology
therapies in their pipeline. The data set is limited
to registrational oncology trials, so predominantly Phase
3, maybe some later Phase 2 studies, but
not early phase clinical trials in this data set.
And we limited the range from 2020 to 2024.
The data was provided by each company, so it was
self-reported.
We then aggregated the data across the different surveys.
And so the data that I'll show is across
regions to get a sense, again, of how US compares.
And
the goal here is really to take a step back and look at patterns
rather than any one sponsor's experience.
So looking at the directional cross-company patterns that
we see, and so it's not meant to be precise benchmarks of any
individual trial.
Before I get into the data, though, I think it's important to
ground this in what actual site
activation involves.
And so it's not just one step, it's a combination really
of regulatory interactions and submissions,
IRB and ethics review, contracting,
and site readiness. And some of this happens in parallel.
Some of it ends up happening sequentially in practice.
And there are aspects of it that are iterative.
And so things like protocol amendments can trigger
re-reviews, contract updates, and so you get these
loops that occur across multiple parts
of this process. And so when we talk about site activation
timelines, we're really talking about how this entire system performs.
And based on that,
can really then dictate
how efficient one can be as you go from a locked protocol to
your first site activated, to a system of sites that are
activated within a clinical trial.
And so I'd like to start walking you through some of the
findings from this survey. So we captured a
few data points. And so first I'm going to show you
one data point around time to first site activation.
And really what this represents is when the final protocol has been
approved, so basically locked to a point where you feel comfortable
approaching sites, to then how long it takes to have your
first site activated.
And I think interestingly, this is where the
story might be a little bit different than what people might expect, where
US actually is performing quite well
compared to other regions, where we're
around 150 days, whereas Europe and
China tend to be much longer. So getting that
first site open in the US doesn't seem to be
the primary issue
here.
And so as we start to look at additional data points
that we captured, this is where things
start to diverge, is when you look beyond just when
the first site is activated. So if you look at the
time to activate 75% of
planned sites, here you can see that the US
actually drops precipitously,
where it takes over 300 days to reach that
milestone,
compared to other countries like South Korea,
where you have around 45 days or roughly 100 to
125 days in other regions.
Additionally, we looked at time to first patient in, and
the US is roughly twice as long there
as well. So about 80 days versus 40 to 50
days
elsewhere. So you're already starting to see delays even at the
earliest stages of enrollment in the US.
And so I think the one key point here in this data is
that, as noted, US is quick to get an
individual site activated,
but certainly slower to scale that up.
And so I think that distinction matters because scaling is what
ultimately is going to drive enrollment and timelines
in terms of increasing your encatchment and the types of
patients that you're able to enroll
in these studies. And so putting this all together,
US, again, first site relatively quickly activated, but then
falls behind when it comes to both early enrollment
and additionally when scaling that activation across
sites. And so I don't think that this is necessarily
attributed to just any single bottleneck.
I think it's something more
systematic across the various processes that I had
shown in my earlier slide. And I think
it's also important to note that
the findings reflect registrational trials, which may differ
from some of the dynamics and conversations we're hearing around
early phase development as
well.So one final data
point just to conclude. One piece
of some of the complexity and that might be
driving some of the delays is around the
protocol process, the complexity of that, and amendments that
can occur. And so we did
a review of regulatory review documents associated with
new drugs approved during the same time period of 2020
to 2024
and quantified the number of protocol amendments that
occurred between these protocol
submission to the agency and when the trial activated.
And what we see is that as protocols go through more versions, the
time to study start increases by
on the order of 70 to 80 days from the original version
to version three or higher. And so as you
go incrementally up the step, you can do some quick
math to see that that's roughly 30 to 60 days every time
you have a new version. And so when you think about what happens on those
types of time cycles, often it's the reviews
associated when it comes to having to reenter your
protocol through the various IRBs at the individual
sites. And so this can have a compounding impact as you're
having to do that across all of the sites that you may have
planned for a specific study.
And so which I think suggests that improving the US trial
enterprise is probably going to require some
coordinated changes across these areas.
So taking a step back, the challenges for the US doesn't
seem to be getting the site open. It's more around the
execution.
And
so going back to this initial slide, I think
within each of these critical areas
associated with the activation
process, there's specific aspects that
can lead to the delays that I've noted here,
including health authority complexity and country-specific
requirements, review processes,
the
need often of having to leverage local IRBs,
and slow or absent adoption of central IRBs,
and the additional kind of review committees that
are in place at each site. For instance,
the contract and budgeting, in addition to the site
setup
and readiness. And I think
reflects the cumulative effect all of these have as you look at
the data that I presented today.
And so I'll save potential solutions or next
steps for the panel discussion, but we'll just conclude thanking
the pharma companies that helped provide the data, many of which I
know are in this room today, as well as my colleague Grace Collins for
helping lead the collection of that data and other colleagues at Friends of
Cancer Research as well. Thank you.
Thank you, Mark. That was
amazing.
Thank you. I'm sure there are going to be lots of questions and a lot of fodder for
the discussion. Jay, do you want to give your...
Do we have that QR code yet, or?
Not yet.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, there's it. So this is the QR code.
We do have a survey at the end. And
do we have a question before Jay's talk, or is it ready to be
queued?
Okay. Do I need to advance the slide to get there?
Maybe make sure everyone gets the QR and then maybe give it a
few seconds.
And then, yeah, let's see.
Arrows are not doing it.
Do you have the question?
So we'll just move forward.
Okay.
It's not advancing.
There's the question. Well, now...
Okay.
Are we okay to go with this?
Yeah.
All right. So Mark did a great job of setting up some things around
challenges with trial activation.
I'm going to talk some more about that, but take a minute and
put your thoughts in here about what you think the biggest barrier
are. You can't say all of the above. Okay?
So you just have to vote on one.
I think
the time's expired. Maybe we go to the next slide.
I think we're having technical difficulties.
Okay. All right.
Only get one vote.
It's D. Everything goes with D. Okay.
If we could just pull up the slides then.
Nice
presentation.
That's good.
Hmm.Great.
Thanks, everybody. All right. So, a site's perspective on
activation. Let's take a few minutes to talk about that.
And I'm going to use a metaphor here to have a little bit of fun with this to say,
do we want to see custom-made or bespoke activation, or do we
want to see things that are more ready-to-wear?
And I'm going to give
my point of view on this is the more ready-to-wear activation can
be, the better. And what are the ways we can get there?
So, no financial disclosures for me, but I am going to disclose some
things about our own internal processes and how things work at Moffitt.
And first, just give you a picture here of
we think we've done a nice job in putting together a sponsor
orientation package. We use this for CROs as well.
How do you work with us? What are the ways for us to navigate
together? It's 40 pages long. And
that's a condensed version of things.
So that's technically something that's giving us
some sense of the complexity that's going on in what we're doing.
Internally,
we have a role that we call the activator role.
That's our role that really drives activation from beginning to end
and connects all of the different teams and the different works that has to
happen. Their work instruction, it's kind of a coincidence.
This is the same number of pages, but
it's also almost 40 pages long, and when you add in the
additional standard operating procedures and other things that are there, you start
to get into the beyond hundreds of pages just to get
oriented around how to serve in that role.
And that's just one role in activation.
Another view, and Mark gave a much cleaner view of activation.
I'm giving you a much
messier view, which is the more detailed kind of steps.
At the bottom of this slide is activation process steps at
Moffitt, the way that we think about them.
At the top, very distinct from that is another metaphor
that we use, that we think about an interstate and the
infrastructure around trial activation being the interstate,
and our trials move through that like a car would move through on the interstate.
And so they move into these major phases that you can see at the top, and it's what
really helps us make sure that we're balancing our capacity
and the demand of trials that are coming through.
Now, the car, the trial, can move in different ways, and we want to make sure that
we continue to evolve how we do that, improve how we do that.
We're really pleased to say we've brought our activation times down at least
in half from what they were several years ago, but there's certainly
more that can be done, and definitely more that can be done if we're
thinking about going across stakeholder groups to be able to accomplish that.
I'm going to zoom into part of that section of that
process map that you couldn't read, and I didn't intend anybody to be able to read
it. It was more the effect of what you see there in complexity.
But that middle section is really what's happening from the point that
we approve a trial from first stage review in the disease site
area, the department,
into feasibility, and then we start working on regulatory
activities, budgeting,
contracting, and all of that, we've moved that to do that before we even
take things to the scientific review committee to give us a head start
on that. But even then, this is complex and has a lot of back and
forth to it.
So we're back to the metaphor here around
are you doing things
made to order, bespoke, or ready-to-wear?
And there's all kinds of examples of the way that this lives today
in ways that are really much more this kind of
customized way at the site level in its interaction with the
CROs, with sponsors, with regulatory
bodies, IRBs, et cetera.
When we fill out a site qualification packet, we often have to fill out a
very similar one within the same CRO or
same sponsor in a different format at times.
And there's time taken in that.
There's many things that are on this slide that kind of are
paralleling the different parts of the outfit that I put here as the metaphor to
say,
I call these protocol-derived work products.
So the protocol has to be translated into
multiple things. It has to be turned into a protocol summary, a
calendar, a budget, a contract,
an ICF. All of those things generally are being done.
We're doing them. We're going back and forth with the CRO, the sponsor,
in an individualized way. And even go a step further to the order
sets that are developed. It's kind of interesting how most, at least of the
major centers, are on the same EMR.
We're moving to that EMR as well in Epic, and yet we all are
developing the order sets individually.
It's a little bit crazy when you think about the individualized steps that are
happening, and I think about it from our colleagues in the CRO and
site or sponsor world, where they're dealing with this times
100, times 1,000. And the complexity just really builds
on itself and is a cumulative thing, as Mark was saying.
So the question really to me is how do we make as many
of these steps
in this ready-to-wear fashion and
systematize it where we can? There are things we can do
inside an organization and make progress, and those things can be sometimes
dramatic, but most of the time, they're incremental.
Where I think the opportunity, and this is why I'm so excited about seeing a
panel like this come together across stakeholder groups that are
involved, is that this is where the opportunity, that kind of
collaboration is where we can make much more dramatic changes.
You add
Advocacy groups from a patient perspective, a policy perspective.
Now we're doing things across the entire United States
clinical trial realm to make changes and simplify and
maybe have some parallels even to some of the things that are advantages
internationally.
So we'll talk more about some of these specifics.
Hopefully, the metaphor stuck for you a little bit.
By the way, I've never had anything done made to order other than maybe
a Halloween costume my wife has made for me to go out with the kids
or something like that. But I thought it worked pretty well for this.
So Lola, I'm going to turn back to you to take us through the discussion.
Thank you, Jay. Nice presentation. Thank you.
So there's a lot to unpack here. I want
to turn it over to our panelists here
to get their immediate reaction to some of the data that
Mark presented. And I also welcome you all if there are things that
you saw that were surprising, or if you want to provide additional color
to some of those data,
I welcome that. So anyone on the panel want to comment on the data that
Mark presented? Bee? Oh, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Anyone.
Thanks so much.
We had reviewed this data in advance, and one thing Mark pointed out,
I just want to highlight again, is that this is for later line,
later stage trials. So I do think the timelines probably are much
more favorable for early stage,
phase one trials or phase two trials, phase one, phase two trials.
With, of course, fewer sites as well.
So it'd be really exciting if we can get further data in that space to better
understand the obstacles and the spread.
So Fonda, could you elaborate on that, on sort of what informs
that perspective? What is it about the early phase
investigational space that you believe is
very different, from a timeline perspective, from later trials?
Yeah. Thanks so much. So,
there's a blend, I think, of course, of trials.
But for phase one, I think both investigators and
pharmaceutical companies feel like that first
activation and first patient on is a metric
of urgency.
Mm-hmm.
So there, for example, even within our institution,
there's quite a bit of spread between departments.
But the phase one group that I lead, we're on a constant go, go,
go mode. And our
pride is to be able to make sure that we are the first site that activated and got
the first patient on.
Mm.
So I think there is also fewer sites usually,
though I have to say that there are some pharma companies that do have 10, 20
sites. That adds complexity in general for investigators.
Mm.
But given that maybe that lag of the tail is also
lagging, that changes the numbers a little bit.
Okay, good.
I wanted to comment on a stat on one of your first slides that you showed,
Mark, that we didn't really discuss yet, which is median number of sites per
country. And so one of the things to comment on is how high
that number was for the US. And the reason why sponsors often open
so many sites is that we know that majority of sites
that open don't actually enroll a patient.
And so this is the deep dive into the data, which is why,
because we know we need US representation, we often target more
sites. More sites means it takes longer to get to 75%
because each complexity is different. So I just wanted to comment on that.
That is different where you might see more standardization or
normalization of that number of median sites per country in oncology.
The other deep dive that is not in that data set, which is
also an important discussion, is the difference we see in timelines between
community-based sites compared to academic centers.
And in our own data from a couple of years ago, we saw that that difference can
be a median of 220 days for an academic site versus
90 days for a community site. So there are complexity differences,
and that may not be the same for every sponsor.
But these are elements that just add a curiosity for
us to really better understand that not all things are created equal, and that
there are things unique to the US. And happy to talk about other
ex-US experience later. I want to come back to some of the
points you made, but I want to get everyone's reaction, because I think you raised
some interesting comments.
Yeah, I was just going to kind of piggyback off of Bee.
I do think something that's super interesting is thinking about these
high-performing community sites and thinking about how they will
have faster activation times, thinking about the
capabilities that they have, and then also
bringing up the fact that anytime we see
any sort of approval, we see a decay in safety and efficacy,
versus the
studies as they are now. But if we can bring in some of those community sites, we
might be able to see a more balanced, actual effect in local
communities. That's a huge piece that I think is important to add here.
Okay.
Go ahead.
So from a patient perspective, what I think is a little bit of a
challenge for patients is
the education and communication part.
Because I think that in the ideal world,
when you go to an academic institution, you have the
opportunity to speak with people who are on the first line of
clinical trials. But normally in the community, that's
not really the case. And I think that
if we could get more education in the community,
even for the oncologists in the community, because there may be a
site in that community that is going to provide the
trial, but they haven't communicated it to the oncologists in
that area. And
patientsReally need to be reassured
that the word clinical trial has
become, in the patient community,
well, maybe that's the last resort.
But clinical trial can be at any point in the treatment
plan, even in from the very beginning, which was my experience.
And they must be assuring the patient, though, if I'm in a
clinical trial, I'm going to still receive standard of care.
Because I think that's a misconception that I'm
not going to be with my treatment
team. As a matter of fact, you'll be more
monitored because you'll have more access to it.
But I think advocates can help in this, in that,
again, in the ideal world, there'd be an advocate
affiliated with every trial. And I know
as an advocate on a trial trying to recruit
patients,
it's easy to
maybe speak with someone who's walked in your shoes than it is
to,
some of the
protocol things that you have to read and then sign,
it's just overwhelming for patients.
And so I just think that better use of advocates
and more education in the community and reinforcing that
if the people in the trial don't look like you,
then we don't know if the drug is going to work.
And I had personal experience looking for a trial for someone, and they
were all being done in China.
And so I just hope that we can overcome that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Judy. You raised so many important and
critical points here. And any additional brief reaction before
I follow up on some of the comments that have already been made? Jay?
I'll just touch on something. I think, Mark, you emphasized it well, but it stood
out to me the first
site to open in the US fast, the others slower.
It's intriguing me to say what's different about the interaction
between the sponsor and our CROs in that first site to
the rest. I think there's a lot to learn there and to understand about how
we can go faster for sites two through whatever it might be.
Mm-hmm. Bee.
One thing I just want to comment, of course, is it's important when this analysis
is done also, for example, in phase one, two trials, there may be a few
sites that were selected for the escalation and then expansion.
So when you look overall, those numbers will be skewed and it's important to
keep that in mind as well.
Yes. That is absolutely an important caveat there.
So I wanted to go back to this issue of the
number of days for activating
community-based sites versus
academic sites. And given that I think we all
appreciate that the majority of patients who are diagnosed
with cancer, are treated with cancer, are treated and diagnosed in the
community setting,
I'm wondering from a sponsor perspective, Bee and
Terrill, if you could comment on whether
and how companies prioritize
where to conduct their clinical trials, their phase two, three
clinical trials.
And maybe I can answer this
with Funda's perspective that we look at the entire
entry into human all the way to registration.
We want to reach as many patients as possible.
And what we've been encouraged about in the last few years is this increase in
participation of community sites in clinical research.
But one of the things that we see as really important is building the capability to
be able to run clinical trials is also very taxing,
costly, requires a lot of resources.
And we saw that with the COVID pandemic, the impact on the number
of educated, experienced professionals who could run clinical trials,
there was a depletion in that workforce. So that affects capacity.
So it's a bit of this challenge that we have in the US that does affect your
ability. But if you think about, as sponsors, we tend to
go to community sites because we want the experience, and we
want to actually reach the patients that we may not always reach at academic
centers. And we also want to build those capabilities at those sites.
But it does then depend on the modality.
If it's a specialized modality with specialized manufacturing considerations like
cell and gene therapy, not every community site will be able to participate unless
they partner with an institution that has those capabilities, for instance.
So phase one capabilities is often a limiting
factor to where we can go. But it is so important because we've also seen
that patients at community sites don't always have the same treatment options
as those that are in urban centers and academic centers.
And we've heard this in multiple panels in the years past, that
rural frontier settings where even just getting basic care,
standard of care, and getting diagnosis can be a barrier.
So really wanting to make sure that we appreciate that it's not that
simple just to say, "I'm going to go to that community site to reach more
patients." To set them up for success and make sure that they can participate in
clinical research on behalf of patients, they also need a lot of support and
help that goes beyond
our will.
Yeah.
So I just wanted to comment.
Yeah. I guess just using the site activation
and how quickly they can get to their numbers.
Oh, the time to... Yeah.
I want to talk about that because obviously they're doing something
right and something different, or there's something different about these sites
that are leading them to be able to meet whatever their quotas
are for enrollment very quickly. And we're hearing in a previous session I
was in that there are actually long lines of patients waiting for
slots and things like that. So I want to sort of go back to the question
of what is it about these community-based sitesThe
ones that have capacity, the ones that are getting their
trials started faster than the large academic center, what is it
about them that makes them able to get to these shorter
timelines?
Yeah.
First I will say it's a matter of education interest at the
local site. If you have a physician that is interested and has
experience running clinical trials, that's huge.
And that will do that. And
I think the way that from a clinical operations perspective, we
look at it is historically, how fast are those timelines,
where those are at. And then do they have
adequate capabilities? Some of our medicines
require special storage, sample handling, et cetera.
And then the other thing that we look at is, are we
going to get a representative sample of patients that
will be in the study? So looking at all those things.
And I think really,
it depends on the indication. It depends on
the type of study. But one of the things that I wanted to bring up
on this panel is we
need network effects for that. Because a lot of the things,
especially that Jay had on his slide, and Mark had on his slide, is
thinking about how much contracting do we need to do?
Do we need to do the same contracts over and over again, or is there a way that we
can net those out
so that we can go faster in those directions?
So
I want to kind of push back a little bit.
So do we think that the contracting takes
less time in these community-based sites, or do we just think that the
trials that are being conducted there are so different
that the complexity of protocols and
contracting and the various components where you may
need additional vendors and so forth is what's leading to the
difference in the site access?
So Lola, tangibly, there's always less process-
Yeah
... at a community site compared to an academic center. There are less lawyers.
And there's also, if you think about the types of studies that we are
doing with community centers, they're ones that make sense to be building those
experiences. So whether it's because they're more simple or
the questions and hypotheses are more straightforward,
we're not taking some of the really intense, high, new
capability work because that's not setting that community site up for success.
Mm-hmm.
And there's less competition.
Academic centers are weighing clinical trials and asks
across so many different disease areas, and they always have to
prioritize. In community sites that are willing and interested and
investing in it,
I think there's less competition in terms of scale.
So those things all lend itself to being much more faster.
And I think they are tangible. So it may not be just contracts.
It could also be that they have a centralized IRB because they don't
have onsite capacity to have a local IRB.
So it really-
Yeah.
Yeah
... those are some of the things that you'll see trend in that direction.
So I'm hearing there's less competition, there are more
patients,
there are fewer lawyers.
Maybe.
Depends on the site.
So to me, it makes sense to invest more in those sites,
right? To go in there and get more patients.
But I hear what you're saying about some of the barriers.
Terry, did you want to say something real quick?
Well, no. I was actually just going to ask Fonda to comment on this as well,
because I think
one of the things she's going to say is,
I guess my question is, how many studies are
you running at the same time? How many people are approaching you at the
same time? What does that look like for you, Fonda?
Yeah. That's a really good question, of course, because
for an individual program, for example, in our Phase 1
program, we do have the opportunity to review across
multiple clinical trials, and we activate 95 trials a year in
our department.
But lack of patients is definitely not an issue, and almost always slot
availability is an issue for us. So it's important to note, especially in early
phase clinical trials, that's a limiting factor.
Mm-hmm.
So we do need to have multiple trials available at the same time to
have every patient that's interested in the trial
to have an option. And that's really our goal.
I guess in thinking about competition for trials,
do you find that, is it your experience that your early phase
trials are competing
for resources,
whatever, with your later phase trial at your institution?
Yeah. Thanks for that question. We do have a unique setup at Anderson.
We actually have a standalone department that does multi-histology Phase
1 trials. So a disease site, like a breast oncologist may see
a breast patient, and they'll definitely look at their own portfolio.
But if they feel that we have something superior or if they don't have an
option, patient will be referred to us.
So we're at all times, while assessing trials, we think
broadly about what do we have, what's coming, and what's
expected to change in the standard of care at the same time.
So it is a delicate process to decide, and we always want to make
sure that we're going to be able to accrue to it before we open it.
Yeah. Thank you. So I want to move and talk about some of the processes
and to sort of... Did you want to make a comment? Okay.
So some of what Jay was discussing around redundant
processes, and Mark also touched upon this.
Could we hear your thoughts a little bit about
some of those startup processes, IRB reviews,
contracting, budget
development,
consent form documents, operational
build, all of those things. Can you comment from your perspectives
around what are critical considerations for
systematizing some of those versus making them more
custom made?
Me first? Mark, do you want to go?
Well, maybe I'll start because I might be a little bit more general than you, but I
was just thinking about how to carry forward the analogy that you
started, and I've been told I'm a tall person, and so I'm just thinking about
ready-to-wear.
It just takes me back to a point I had been thinking about.
I think it is a good place to start with ready-to-wear, and
I don't think that though means you can't tailor
what you have.
And so standardization doesn't need to mean uniformity, and I think
it could mean that there's just common starting points that everyone
is beginning from, but obviously can allow for some
negotiation from there. I think the challenge is when you're having to
start from scratch every single time.
In
some of our conversations with various pharma companies as we were capturing this
data, we were curious as you
do these clinical trials, it's not as though you're likely going to
different sites every time. There's probably a
set of sites that are high on your list, either due to they're high
functioning
or have a representative set of
patients. But what was kind of
concerning in some ways is that even though they may have
these frequent encounters, it doesn't mean
shorter times in terms of conducting these processes.
So even though you've already gone through this for one clinical
development program, it's as though you've never
had these discussions before when you go with an additional clinical development
program. And to me, that just doesn't seem to kind of
make sense. And I would be curious to kind of hear some of the
factors that drive that, but it certainly seems that there would
be opportunities to harmonize or
standardize some of these components to
alleviate some of that.
Jay, could you comment on some of that standardization?
Sure. Yeah. I'll talk about contracting for a minute, and
there's been good...
I'm going to
give some positive things about attorneys here in this answer, actually.
Although we know that the more back and forth there is overall, that can cause
challenges. We've a little bit of an anecdote at Moffitt.
I would say
contracting actually isn't a timeliness issue for us.
It used to be. But our Office of General
Counsel has done an amazing job being able to get in
sync with the market on positions within terms and
conditions in contracting. That's something that happened about a year
ago and has had a phenomenal impact on us in terms of the back and
forth that occurs. They're on
things that seem somewhat... Well, they're about specimens.
There's about subject injury language, payment terms.
There's about a dozen of these kinds of things that are pretty common in
every agreement, but you can get stuck on
one or two of them.
The thing that's interesting is how do you know if you're out of bounds with the
industry? How do you know you're in alignment or not?
We had to do some benchmarking to be able to help us do that.
But what if that was already out there in some way,
nationally, where that's the starting point that Mark was talking about,
where the back and forths times thousands
that you could reduce by having some of that standardization in place there.
There's budgeting. It could be applied.
It's a little trickier with
the budgeting and the way our system is set up, and maybe we'll talk some about
that going forward, but there's starting points there too
that we don't have to be beginning from the point of this
calendar for everybody that had to build it to then
translate that into a budget. It just seems like a task that's not
necessary.
Yeah.
Go ahead, Judy.
I was just going to ask a question. So I didn't realize till I was in
this discussion with this panel that when you go from Phase 1
to Phase
2, that has to go through each site's IRB again,
and the protocol has to be reviewed again.
And I know when we had to change our protocol because a new drug came out
so that we would maintain standard of care,
IRB review took weeks to come back.
So what I'm wondering is, is there any way to make a
standard
department or a standard,
I don't know, the bureau that would say, "Okay, this
protocol's been reviewed. The
IRB has approved it. They're an accepted place, and why
waste time when
I don't understand as a patient why they have to review it at every
site if it's been working?"
That is a fantastic point.
I think we have been discussing this for a
long time, and I think it's time to operationalize this
idea of
centralized IRBs, but also not just
centralized IRBs, but if your study has been
reviewed at MD Anderson or Columbia
University or wherever, does it need to be reviewed at
every single subsequent academic major
or whatever other clinical trial site?
Yeah.
And I'm sure that there will be people who will raise their hands and say, "Yes,
absolutely, because X, Y, Z." But really, I think
I'm not so much
interested in why we can't do the things.
Mm-hmm.
More interested in what are the things we must do.
And this issue of IRBs is something we
must do.What are your thoughts on this?
Well, even in this particular case, so when we changed the
protocol, it had to go to the FDA,
obviously.
So I'm saying it's getting validated over and over again by the
time it goes to the multi-site. So why do we
have to delay it by going through other lawyers? My son's a lawyer.
I know what that's like.
I never won any arguments when he was a teenager, but
I just don't see how it's helping patients.
And I
didn't
know until-
Yeah
... I was in this panel that that was happening.
I mean, for clarification, of course, sometimes the Phase II is a separate
trial altogether, and you're starting from scratch. Sometimes it's an amendment.
One of the problems with amendment, I think, is that
most institutions are very focused on timelines of the
activation.
Mm-hmm.
But they don't have the same metric tracking for amendments.
So I feel that we could definitely do much better with amendments.
And there's an incredible amount of time lost, for example, informed consent
language that's changed very subtly.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. I
don't know. There might be some people here that I'm not going to make friends
with, but
Moffitt,
we do not have an IRB. We use central IRBs.
Our central IRBs are very fast, very good in terms of getting things
back. But to the points that are made here, we're
submitting things to those IRBs, and we use
one predominantly and another one a little bit less, that many other
places are sending the same study to at the same phase, at the same
version of amendments.
If I explain that to somebody outside of clinical trials, they would scratch their
head at that, why that's happening that way.
So I think, Judy, to your point, there's opportunities.
So Bee, you were going to make a comment?
This is actually a great topic to comment on what happens outside the US,
which we can learn from. So the reason why you saw the metrics on Mark's slide
in which it takes so much more time to get to your FPI, your first patient in,
is because there are centralized, nationalized procedures for
your clinical trial application review, your ethics committee review, which is
their version of the IRB at the national level often.
And then there is that processing of all upfront, that
information. And then once that's done, it's done nationally
for every clinical trial site. Doesn't matter if they're small, if big, academic or
not, that basically under that clinical trial application,
they've been approved.
Mm-hmm.
So that also means amendments are centralized and approved with
more predictability. So it's really important to see that it
can be done, but it had to be done nationally.
And the one aspect that underlines our entire conversation, which is really
important, is both FDA is a very
mature regulator that is very robust and rigorous.
And to change, either anything that FDA does or anything in our
system, is always more difficult when it's embedded and
entrenched.
Outside the US, we see that there are government
systems forming and creating their legislative, and
maturing their legislative systems.
So their will to change and their ability to then kind of move
that rock uphill is easier because they're not as
entrenched. So I think this is a really important dynamic to consider, and
that's also the arguments you will see about IRB review and related
to risk assessment.
Mm-hmm.
But outside the US, that's what contributes to predictable,
standard timelines that can be much faster overall,
which is why we really pushed and supported Friends' assessment of the
75% of sites because that's more indicative of the overall
trial performance than first site activated.
That's a really great point that you raised there, Bee,
around sort of the less mature or less
entrenched regulatory organizations that have had the benefit to
learn the dos and don'ts from the US system,
but that are also obviously more flexible to implement changes
that
bring efficiency into the review system.
So we've talked about centralized IRB.
I don't think we have any oppositions to centralized IRBs.
The question around one IRB review
nationally for a trial opened in the US,
does anyone have any--
Can identify any obvious,
really challenging roadblocks to that?
Yeah.
And please, as the audience, I invite you also to comment on some of these
questions.
So this is what I meant about risk assessment, that the appetite for risk
per organization, including sponsors, will always
look different. And the US is such an important market with this
idea that bespoke to some degree is part of our
entrenched culture.
It's like, "But I'm an exception." There's reasons why we need to cover risk,
especially at our organization. So there is a challenge there
because when you design a way of working
nationally to start from, versus working backwards to try to
retrospectively change it from a local to national,
and the size of the US, the number
of institutions, it's easier in a much smaller country
where you don't have as many sites overall.
Yeah.
So I think that's a scale issue.
Any incentives to participating in a
national IRB
program or pilot, and if you don't
participate, maybe you won't get these choice
trials at your clinical site. Are there any carrots
that could be dangled? Are there any sticks for
maybe not embracing this concept?
I would just say the sticks are the
US is the largest major market that companies have.
I think that's the carrot, too, right?
Is we want to-
Everyone is trying to market in the US, and the US has this fabulous standard
of care. And I think all of those reasons
make it
attractive just in general. So, I think whatever we can
do to standardize things as much as possible to
leverage. And I think to our earlier discussion, I think it's
both in the community setting and then also in the academic
setting, where we need to figure out how to
adjust protocols for both of those settings in a
way. So there's going to be things that are bespoke in the US.
I see what you mean.
It's also worth, I think, looking at the data to see how often
is
central IRB faster and what are the differences.
So if we're going to recommend something, it should be data-driven.
Thank you. I'll take the...
Hi. I'm Denise Renke. I'm at the University of Michigan, and I'm
administratively part of a team that does sarcoma research.
And I want to share an example that I think is relevant to this discussion of a
single IRB. So the NCI has attempted to
centralize this by saying that if you've got NIH or
NCI funding to do the research, and you're doing
multi-institutional, you must use a single IRB.
And so recently, we have that exact situation working with
large academic centers, six centers.
They all signed an agreement to cede to a single
academic IRB.
Unfortunately, each site still had to go through
scientific review, go to their IRBs.
So even though it was mandated, and they all agreed to do
it, and it was really meant to jumpstart things and move
forth to activation much more quickly, and even when everybody
agreed to it. So I think it's a worthwhile example to look
at because, as you think about doing this broadly
across the community, it has been tried, and unfortunately, academic
institutions are very resistant to
letting go. Even though they sign that paper, they still feel a
legal, ethical obligation to have their IRBs
review and sign off. So, I think it would help to move
things along more quickly, but we've tried it, and there have been
still some obstacles.
Thank you for that perspective. That's very helpful.
And I think we've got to make it work because it
just seems unnecessary. Bea, did you want to make a quick
comment? I want to move on, too.
I did want to just say that there is an element that's
also underlying all of this, which is why you have to take the data with a grain
of salt. In the 20 to 24 time frame,
that's when we saw the massive shift of trial data being generated
outside the US. And so the caveat to that data is that
there was a pause on clinical trial capabilities and research during the
first two major waves of the COVID pandemic.
So that does affect the data. But what we learned from that is that
when we do multi-regional clinical trials, we do competitive enrollment,
meaning we open everyone, we start at the same time, and whoever gets up and
running, you enroll as many patients, and we hadn't considered regional
capping. And so we have several examples of pivotal
studies where the footprint of the multi-regional clinical trial completely
changed because of what happened during COVID in the
US. And we didn't plan it. We wanted patients in the US.
But what happens is then by the time the US sites were up and running, we were
at capacity, and we weren't enrolling that study anymore, or we'd reached our
number of patients needed. So now you'll see a shift in sponsors
trying to correct for this. Now, because of the work with FDA and
the discussion about the need for US patients, we're trying to figure out how to
generate the right amount of patients in the US, but also
still do a global multi-regional clinical trial.
So you might start to see operationally capping of number of patients per
region. You might see that there is an extra effort to generate additional
data to supplement that pivotal study.
So
actually, there's a lag time from when you recognize a trend and
an issue and trying to fix it. So all of those things are really important
because then, even if we're able to improve some of these
timelines, we still have to think about how fast some of these
other countries are enrolling and then how to operationally ensure that we
have enough patients in the US, which then allows us to then file the
application and market.
Thanks, Bea.
Marc, did you want to-
Not to elongate this, but I guess just a couple of comments, and I appreciated
the comment made from
the participant. I was going to also mention the fact that
in NCI-sponsored trials, there
is often a desire, if not a requirement that central
IRB be used, but it's helpful to know that even there, there
continues to be some challenges.
I'm thinking out loud, so that could be dangerous.
But as I think about this, and I have to kind of think it through all the
way, but
I think at this point, we've been saying how can we
shift entirely away from local IRB to central IRB?
So, really an all or nothing, which might be
a difficult pill to swallow right away.
And so are there some opportunities for a middle ground?
For instance,
maybe it's hard for the local IRBs to let go, but
is there some initial review up front that's done at the local
IRB, but then once theOnce things have gotten underway
and moving forward, could things then transition to
a central IRB? Because as noted in some of the data,
every time you have a protocol amendment, it certainly could seem to be much more
efficient if, for the subsequent amendments that occur after the
local IRB's already reviewed, to go quicker if you're
just going through one single IRB versus having it trickle through
all the institutions. So it's somewhat of a
middle ground, and so maybe it, in some ways, could be incremental
but could still have a positive impact at the end.
Additionally, in some of our round conversations
we've had prior to this, having people that have sat on
IRBs and scientific
review committees at local institutions, I think
many have noted there's often a need up front to
remind people what the purpose of, say, an IRB review
is and to avoid scope
creep. And what I mean by that is, I think an
IRB is really meant to
ensure patient safety, but I've heard from some
that they feel this is their opportunity to
make
points and comments to the sponsor because
they feel that they don't have another mechanism, or through scientific
review, suggesting additional data elements that should be
collected. And
all of that, while
it may sound
harmless, I think it does have implications, again, that's compounding
all of the delays.
Yeah. And I appreciate the comments there.
I think
we have to be bold, and I think that these incremental
middle ground things, there's going to be
more justification as to why it's got to be
local versus central, and then you're going to end up
in the right place. So for me,
I think our recommendation here should be central IRB for
initial review and for
subsequent protocol modifications.
Can I add a point on this? I think it might be worthwhile for us to
do a deep dive as to the remit and scope of ethics committees
outside that are national level, because it's not an IRB, it's an
ethics committee, and it's focused on is their
equipoise for patients and safety protected?
So, versus I think the remit and scope of IRBs tend
to include also these additional aspects that might be
scientific review, institutional protection, and risk assessment.
And so the ethics committee is really looking at the level
of are patients treated
appropriately in this hypothesis testing of the clinical trial.
That's something I think could be nationalized in the US
so that that becomes not something ...
Because I think what we're trying to do is we're trying to solve all the issues
that come up at IRBs, which the ethics committees never go
into at the national level. They don't scrutinize whether or not the sponsor's
paying for transportation for the clinical trial and seen as an incentive.
So there's certain differences that maybe the first step actually is to deep dive
in what would be the recommendation for a nationalized version of
an ethics committee in the US.
Yeah. And to even anchor all of this
to evidence, I like your
recommendation, but I think it would also be interesting to
know the extent to which the variability
in IRB recommendations for revisions
leads to substantial risk
assessment differences.
Because it's one thing to say, "Why don't you
do this? Why are you doing an extra biopsy?
Why aren't you doing an extra biopsy?"
How does that actually lead to a substantial,
meaningful change in how you design
and conduct a clinical trial and the evidence that you generate from it?
Any additional ...
Yeah. I'd like to comment on the scientific review aspect of it, especially
relevant for cancer center support grant supported centers.
There's a mandate for scientific review as well.
And I think one of the things that we're finding is that these
used to be done sequentially, which are, by definition, at a time.
And these, especially if we use a central IRB, these can be now done in parallel,
where the scientific review committee can assess things.
And even that I think is now messaged at our institution better.
For example, a few years ago, our statisticians were so
brilliant. They'd always read it, and they'd say, "Oh, I could have designed
the study better," and then go off on a tangent.
And now, they realize the question is, "Is there really something
deeply flawed with the statistics?
Is there something that needs an explanation?" Not, "Can you have done this
better?"
Exactly. Yeah. All right. Thanks.
All right.
Lola, there's a-
She's going to ... Oh, sorry.
Hi. I wanted to make a comment about the central IRB and the
local context. I think one of the awesome things that was done for
us was the advent of the central IRB and the acculturation and development of
SOPs for deferring to the central IRB.
But I think a solution here that may be more effective than some
kind of mini local IRB and trying to do a deep dive is really talking
about that deferral process. So every local
IRB. I'm Julie Bauman, I'm from George Washington University.
I'm the cancer center director there, and yes, this is something we obsess about,
time to activation. But acculturating an
organization and their ethics system to
defer requires them to develop robust processes that
then they trust.
And so there's two aspects to that.
One of them is cost, so there needs to be built in that there's a payment
mechanism for
using a central IRB, and that's typically the case
with... industry-sponsored trials.
However, if you don't get to that executed CTA,
and you've already executed that deferral, then you may not
get paid for it. So this is something that gets people
running in circles. But the second thing is organizations
that aren't that experienced with clinical research
paradigms and the evolution of the central
IRB and that ability to defer, and having a
process that enables you to know what is your portfolio that's deferred,
which is what makes compliance officers go crazy in the middle of the night.
So I think that's the institution's work, is to
develop a robust SOP for that deferral
process. That should take days. They
shouldn't have to have a preliminary review.
And there are really nice examples for this.
So, I wanted to make that comment because I think that's a way to telescope
this process more than to
accept the idea that each institution needs to have a bespoke mini
review that is probably not that helpful to the field.
And the second thing, I had a question for Jay.
You talked about obtaining some benchmarking.
And I'm curious about what you went to for that
benchmarking.
Sure.
We engaged with a consulting firm
that has done a lot of work with the
activation process out there, and
their own legal team was able to look at what we were doing and our positions
and give us a sense of that. So it wasn't a publicly
available
benchmarking, but it was a really valuable exercise that they did with us.
And a very honest one to say, "This is your
position. This is what we see as the common positions.
Here's what we would suggest." And went through those kind of one point at a
time.
Could you provide your thought process around this
deferral process and whether that needs to be institution by
institution as well? Because that just then creates just kind of
another
process that could be-
So most institutions do now have a deferral process for deferring to the
central IRB.
So they know what body of work they have deferred if they're opening a
cooperative group trial, for example.
And so their IRBs have developed mechanisms for that.
And that is where the scientific review says it's
expedited, and then it goes to the IRB for the
deferral process. And it's submitted deliberately for the deferral process.
And so the organization where I am four
years ago did not have such a process.
So it's acculturating and benchmarking the
compliance and ethics offices to
developing these processes, and this is where
sort of a central repository of knowledge and SOPs could be really
helpful. How do you promulgate that from one institution to another?
How do we learn from each other?
Yeah.
Could we... Oh, sorry.
Sorry, could I?
What I would want to just add is with patient
recruitment being important to
facilitate. And in the United States with the HIPAA
laws, it becomes a little bit tricky sometimes to find
patients that are qualified. Whereas like in Japan, it's a centralized
system and centralized database.
But if we had a form that patients could
sign in the beginning that says, "Are you interested in participating in a
clinical trial if we find something that matches with
your tumor
type?"
And then that way, that we could get access to patients that
might want to participate
rather than go looking for patients.
And usually,
my experience is that it just requires an extra tube of blood being
drawn at one point, and that's kept on record.
But the results are made available to
the institution that they're being treated at so that if something comes
along, they have these people already
pre-authorized.
I think that's an excellent point.
And I think one of the things that I
actually think we are also lacking and that we
should think about is this idea of
having really easy access to all ongoing
clinical trials at any time in the United States.
Have that be linked to EMRs.
Because I think we've talked about
most patients getting their cancer care in community settings.
And we
haven't talked about this in this, but we've had conversations around the
time
it takes and the resources it takes for those community
oncologists to keep up. Actually, it's impossible to
keep up with all of the clinical trials that are ongoing at any given time,
and how the system is they're not incentivized, really, to spend a
lot of time looking for clinical trials.
And so,
is there a way, and I'm asking the panel here,
are there any barriers to creating a system
whereby every single patient
has access through the availability of what clinical
trials are ongoing at the very least within their
catchment area,
but that is done without a lot of effort from the
oncologists to identify?
I think,
and we haven't talked about AI on this panel, which is
shocking.
But I think
There is a huge opportunity now to have access
to large databases of information and be able to tease through
that using some of these technologies.
And I know that there are many different
vendors and sponsors who are really looking into this
because there's such an opportunity.
And
the way people have traditionally done it is calling
someone or hearing a rumor, and so I think
the era of that has got to end.
Yeah. I agree. I just wanted to comment that also,
whether you agree with it or not, something that's working really well in China
is that their entire data and system infrastructure is all connected
and seamless. So I think the main barrier, Lola, is our
systems aren't connected and talk to each other in the same way
that they do outside the US because they weren't designed that way.
Yeah.
And in fact, sometimes we're incentivized with different providers and vendors.
So just know that that's always going to be a barrier, is that information
exchange is always easier when you're all in the same system.
And then secondly, that this point that Judy's making,
that clinical research can be positioned as
another treatment option in real time along the entire continuum of
disease, which is a capability that I think we can continue to
build in the US. But to your point, that means creating time,
resources, the ability to have that conversation.
And at all sites, I think that is something that could be our
blue sky dream, but how to get there.
We'll need that additional support to be set up for success.
We're all about blue sky dreams here.
So we have
less than 10 minutes to go, and there are a few things I want to make sure we touch
upon. And one of the things I wanted to discuss is,
are our current incentives
aligned with the things that we're talking about that seem to
be reasonable solutions to some of these issues?
Where are we dis-incentivized?
Where are we not incentivized to
actually implement some of these solutions that we're discussing
today?
So thinking about contracting,
centralized procedures, like clinical trial reviews,
contracting.
Can the same
protocol element cost the same across
all the sites?
And if not, why not?
The main reason is that our insurance systems and payment systems
are also not harmonized.
But you're onto something here, Lola.
So blue sky thinking is to get to that blue sky, you do have to make some
incremental changes, and some things are easier to do to then shift the
culture to say, "Okay, it's possible." And so I wouldn't say the entire
contract could be standardized, but there's for sure elements.
Mm-hmm.
And there's for sure protocol related
segments. So you could even think about it from a blockchain perspective.
What could be more standardized and available?
But it takes the work to figure out what that could be, and I'm not sure every
stakeholder has the time and effort, and to be incentivized to even have that
conversation. So it happening at the national level is really important.
Having government support, having FDA support for sure is a great incentive.
Yeah.
But just know that sponsors are fully incentivized to do research in the US.
That's not the issue. It's just how do we do it faster?
Yeah.
Right.
There's a question online about
could we discuss opportunities for multiple sites to put through an
activation process together? So
working out the legal risk IRB issues.
Yeah.
If not nationally, can this be done just smaller?
Just three.
Yeah, I think there are some central networks, and there
are some CROs that kind of have a one contract, one
budget to be consistent across tons of sites, and I
think that's the kind of model that we
need to leverage more and more. I think it's going to be an
incremental shift. And then something
you and I were talking about this morning is
getting sponsors to work together.
It's not just Gilead, it's not just Roche.
It's got to be all of the sponsors kind of coming together and
working on that.
But touching all of our stakeholders, right?
So I think it's going to be complicated, but if
we can all kind of get together.
Mm-hmm.
Jay, did you have something?
I was going to say, I love the idea that was online to do that because I haven't
seen or heard of that happening outside of across
organizations or systems that already do that.
So I think that
to combine with that and the previous question about incentivizing,
there's such a concern within a center that they're going to be able
to cover their costs and be able
to continue to maintain what they do.
Well, part of that comes then into the complexity of being able to
understand what your costs are, and the more that that could be
simplified in the way that whether it's this is how things are done, we're
not having to look at the... About half of the cost of running
trials for us is the support of the conduct of the trial.
So I think there's a lot of things we could do there to make that
more straightforward, and maybe it's got some flex to it.
Of course, there's
where you live in the United States and salary differences and things like that,
but I think definite opportunities.
Do we have any thoughts about how we can make some of this
information more transparent across sites, across
institutions? How much things cost, where the biggest
costs are, and how much are related to the actual trial
versus overhead and other things?
Where they might be-...
you know, teams, functions, otherwise that are set
up that actually
are contrary to more efficiency and lower
costs?
Sorry. One of the things that I think would be helpful is that you actually
have a neutral party do benchmarking.
Because, to be honest, it's a competitive advantage to be able to
negotiate different costs. So to be able to expect everyone to just
volunteer their information is unlikely.
But one of the things that I love about these conversations is it highlights an
issue, and then it results in people getting curious and wanting the
benchmarking. So I guess my call to action for everyone in the
audience is that if you learn something from today, can you go pull that and be
curious? And
EQVIA, for instance, or businesses that do benchmarking, SiteLine,
Trial Trove, they go and look for things that people want to hear about.
Mm-hmm.
And so the more we talk about it, the more we're going to get benchmarking
information that gives us, is that actually true?
Mm-hmm.
Are the data supporting the hypothesis that there are things that could be
standardized that aren't?
Mm-hmm.
And maybe it tells us something that we didn't know before.
So my point is I think we probably have to go that
way.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I really love where you're going with that.
For anybody who is representing a center here, I think the call to action is
to understand what the costs are to run a trial.
Most centers don't have a good way of doing cost accounting the
same way that they would for standard of care.
That's where a lot of our efforts have been at Moffitt over the last number of
years to be able to do that, to do something that represents something
like a P&L kind of income statement on
trials. What we do with it, as just a quick
example,
the cost center structure within our organization,
trials eat into about 300 to 400 different cost
centers where the work's actually getting done.
So a way to aggregate that back, like it's a service line,
is a step that we all can take. And how can we help each other
do that, that maybe aren't set up to do that? Then you can get to the benchmarking.
In the
two minutes that we have, I'm going to open it up to see if there are any questions
from the audience. Let me see if there are some here that I can take that haven't
been addressed.
I think, Judy, this one is for you. If there was an advocate
for every trial, what specific outreach activities could they
do that would be most helpful?
Well, I think that
there's a patient
equity and-- I actually have a slide on that.
To reassure the patient that they are going to be
supported in every
sense of the way,
that issues that come up, or a side effect.
A lot of patients are afraid to be honest
with the doctor when they're on a drug because they don't want to be taken
off the trial.
Where
in actual fact, if they were honest, they could
either have a
dose reduction, or they could
have some medication to
mitigate that. And so
I think that, again, I go back to the same thing, communication, is
that the patients feel comfortable at every step of the
way to ask questions,
and
that they're given the access, whether they need
transportation to get there or that their time is
valued. Do they need to have three blood draws, really?
And respect.
Respect for the patient's time and...
I'm going to run out of time here, but I think that's the key,
is keeping that paramount
for ethics.
Right. Thanks.
Any other? Yeah.
Yeah. I wanted to thank you all for the discussion today, and maybe just...
I think it's such an important topic to continue after today.
And one way we've done this at ESMO was to
have an industry strategic forum with the medical society.
So maybe post hoc of this meeting, if there was an opportunity to
continue the discussions with the stakeholders up here.
I think it's a very worthwhile cause. So thank you so much for the panel today.
Thank you.
Greetings. Kimlyn Ashing, City of Hope.
So I know we're talking broad regulatory, but I think one of
the missing
opportunities that's incumbent upon the researchers is the
training that we receive, right? We all have to do CITI training or
new trainings that's coming. And so can these
modules be leveraged to include some of these
components that's not already there that should be, so that
researchers are also prepared to be more ethical, to be
more patient responsive and respectful,
and to include some of these regulatory in the training that we
have to do every three to five years, depending on the type of
studies we do.
Yeah. That's a great point. Thank you for that.
And I think probably it's a very heavy burden on
sites to have to train
for things that are really duplicative across many
trials for every single trial. And so part of the
thinking could be what can we
learn? Maybe once a year, we get that certification, but we don't have to
do it every single time we start a trial. That can be carried through.
So,
do we have the
last survey?
I want to be respectful of the time.
I want to take this opportunity to thank the panel for a
really insightful, rich
conversation and discussion. I want to thank the audience for your
participation and engagement, and I want to thank AACR for their
commitment to continuing to discuss this issue, but to also
working towards solutions that can be
implemented. We have one last survey here for
you. Which solution discussed today would most improve oncology
trial startup timelines if implemented tomorrow?
So please give us your thoughts around
how we can prioritize this and what's
feasible to do.
You probably can do this also later on, but if you can
share your thoughts on this, this would be helpful.
I also want to
let you know that the next session in this room will start in about 45
minutes at 12:30. Maybe not 45 minutes.
It's titled "Cancer Prevention and Screening: Exploring
Policy Solutions."
And later on today, the regulatory science and policy
track will resume again in this room with two back-to-back
sessions on various aspects of pediatric cancer
drug development. Thank you for your attention and participation.